[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait faire
quelque chose et ici alors je vous dis
oui
didier non tu avais ma gueule de toute
l'ariège faire refaire vos isabelle je
leur attaqué parce que jacquet alors je
vous dis
il ya une rumeur sur twitter je vous dis
la vérité vous concernant regardez on a
le tweet je vous jure que c'est vrai il
ya une rumeur qui vous concerne isabelle
regarder et la douleur affirme que tu as
eu recours à la chirurgie esthétique
isabelle est ce que c'est vrai
maintenant pas du tout pareil que vous
avez vous fait il est fou mais alors je
vous jure que c'est vrai et c'est pas la
première fois qu'on voit ce tweet ah
mais non mais non mais je suis désolé
mais non c'est vrai cela dit si c'est
vrai c'est raté les normes parce qu'ils
ont de la joue bien et vous ici personne
j'avais déjà vu d'autres projets oui les
bleus c'est le bide aussi bas c'est pas
la chirurgie si vous avez fait le vent
trop sinon j'ai pas fait de liposuccion
j'ai juste mais vous savez une méthode
nommée delà du froid qui glace la grèce
voilà cela criait au jeu
mais l'opération s'est voilà sa basse en
cours et je vais faire les yeux bientôt
non avec singer les paupières malécot
pierres qui tombent sur l'oeil ça c'est
de famille voilà j'ai la peau pierres
qui tombent sur l'oeil un peu comme avec
dsk et je vais faire aussi les poches
n'ai fait que ce point comme agde et ce
car je connais le proverbe
jusqu'à trente ans on a la gueule qu'on
après 30 ans à la gueule qu'on mérite
c'est exactement là j'ai passé trente
ans je garderai a été ignorée de
l'escale et vous avez déjà fait route
fait un truc mais évidemment pas se voir
ailleurs non mais parce que vous c'est
pas la chirurgie esthétique vous avez
affaire à des délires en fait vous savez
pas makukula parti dans un délire genre
vous tient pas soit ils égorgent et même
dans mon froc
à l'école on regarde la vérité la vérité
la vérité elle n'est pas lé pa locale la
vérité si tu veux c'est qu'on vient
d'ailleurs tout laisser ça fait comme on
le sait pas c'est vrai qu'en partir de
là c'est vrai pas comment des rumeurs
peuvent s'élever
non mais ce sommet ils n'ont jamais rien
fait mais c'est absolument mettre
combien d'ailleurs comme ça sourit
didier les gars chez vous il faut tout
refaire
c'est méchant ça où tu te calmes un peu
d'idée quand même je te le dis pour
thoiras sur cd ou fluo boîte il se casse
en deux temps forts le prix c'est vrai
concentré en bois les nanas avec eux il
est vrai mais tout aussi les aussi je te
dire modestement
c'est aussi parce qu'on est deux jeux
vidéos viennent d'ailleurs tourné
[Applaudissements]